♪ ♪
ANNOUNCER:
And now a special message
from the 45th and final
president of the United States.
Hello, my fellow America.
I want to take a minute
to respond
to my response to my speech.
First of all,
I want to thank
all my supporters
and people who donated money
to my presidency.
I mean, my campaign.
I mean, my children's
legal defense fund.
They're the best.
Their names are scrolling below,
just like on my Web site.
I'm so proud
to have taken their money.
I can't believe the Democrats
had that idiot Kennedy
give their lame response.
I was surprised to learn
it wasn't
the MTV veejay Kennedy.
It was one of the ones
that usually die.
I didn't listen
to a word he said,
but I can't believe
he promised amnesty
to everyone in Ms. 13.
MAUREEN:
Sir, I think you mean MS-13.
Okay. Well,
I'd like to meet Ms. 13,
if you know what I mean.
Tonight, I was able
to point at a lot of brave
and honorable people
and make people clap for them,
which made me feel
like they were clapping for me.
I'm amazing.
But there are a lot of people
I didn't get to acknowledge.
I wanted...
(spits)
That's stale.
I wanted to thank Bill Clinton
for not bringing
all the women who have accused
me of sexual assault.
We just didn't have any room
for 19 credible accusers.
I pointed
to a lot of heroes tonight,
but my favorite one
wasn't even in the room,
a great American hero,
a symbol for everything
this country stands for,
who is being forced
into retirement too soon.
We will miss you, Chief Wahoo.
Our nation owes you a great debt
and a lot of land.
There's
an extremely brave immigrant
who has spent the last 13 years
in sheer agony.
She was taken from her homeland
and forced into a life
she never wanted
and can't escape.
I love you, Melania.
That's why we showed up tonight
in two separate cars.
I created jobs
for two separate drivers.
"Honk, honk," goes my car.
"Vroom, vroom," goes her car.
So many honks.
So many vrooms.
You're welcome, America.
♪ ♪